okay man bereit
321 hey leute was glaubt willkommen beim
neuen bio und ja heute ist es endlich an
der zeit ganz lange drauf gucke zwei
wochen untersucht auf jeden fall habe
ich alles video gemacht habe ich so ein
paar richtig hässliche klamotten
vorgestellt und dann auch so ein paar
typen also längst getragen und ich habe
gesagt wenn dieses video keine ahnung
20.000 leicht schafft oder so dann
bestelle ich mir auch mal sowas megans
heißt das allerdings nicht leggins für
männer heißt es megan swingman und
leggings halt so eine mischung hat das
video hat das video natürlich geschafft
hierhin ist nicht so zu machen
eigentlich gestern kam mein vater mein
zimmer und meinte ja alles was für dich
gekommen da habe ich mich natürlich
direkt gefreut es geht und hier in ihrem
paket ist meine erste megans scheiße ich
habe es natürlich extra noch nicht
aufgemacht ich würde sagen wir machen
das jetzt mal zusammen
aber wir weg zuerst die
kameraperspektive damit ich mir auch
gleich dann direkt schön umziehen kann
da freut euch drauf oder ja auf jeden
fall sind wir jetzt hier gelandet
ich würd sagen wir machen das jetzt mal
auf ich bin echt gespannt ich habe nicht
reingefunden sieht man jetzt ich hoffe
da ist überhaupt die e mails können
also das natürlich das erste und letzte
mal dass ich das tragen werde heute in
diesem video
wir holen das mal raus ich kann mir gar
nicht vorstellen wie man sowas ernst
meinen kann wenn ich das geradezu an
druck gegen die bisschen cool
die kommen einfach aus china crazy ey
guck mal
sie kommt aus china könnten also das
sind zumindest chinesische zeichen oder
japanisch wagen nicht ich würde sagen
ich habe gerade noch mal eine
jogginghose jahren beziehe ich mal eben
aus könnte ja gerade nicht sehen
also eigentlich mache ich immer nur in
boxershorts videos könnt ihr sehen
erwartet und ich muss mal kurz für die
kameraperspektive anpassen damit ihr
mich komplett sehen könnt so da aber ich
muss mir noch so ein schild rossmann
kennt ihr das ich mache das einfach bei
allen klamotten sodann dann nehme ich
das nie so kurz danach einfach so scheiß
drauf etwas kaputt geht man jetzt ist
der moment gekommen sie das jetzt mal an
das fühlt sich schon richtig eklig an
okay man bereit
ok 32
ballert oder nein
also um ehrlich zu sein einfach mal
dieses muster das ist doch echt ich guck
mal so blitze ok man kann so was
natürlich so einfach so normal tragen
aber ich habe gedacht ich kombiniere ist
einfach mal so wie die meisten zwerger
das machen und zwar mache ich das so ich
habe mir was drauf gesucht die ziehen
einfach hier darüber noch so eine hose
und dann sieht man nur so diese blitze
so darunter das mache ich jetzt okay was
auf ist schon mal besser finde ich das
ist heftig oder guckt mal okay und kommt
jetzt auch zu meinen schuhen 40 auch
noch mal dazu hören und dann haben wir
das auto schon komplett repariert hat
auch wenn die kommentare auf einer skala
von 1-10 für die derzeit 1 ist scheiße
und 10 ist geil und vielleicht
entscheidet sich auch der eine andere
pille 2 an stand 1 1 ich glaube ich ja
weiteren unter allen in die kommentare
schreiben verlose ich natürlich diese
megans weil ich glaub die ziehe ich nie
wieder an hoffe ich zumindest ansatz
würde ich sagen wenn euch das video
gefallen hat oder eigentlich so ich habe
mir jetzt eine menge ist bestellt da
kann man auch ruhig mal daumen nach oben
da lassen oder ich finde so daumen nach
oben ist immer cool würde mich freuen
wir uns sonntag wie das national thermal
zeige wenn links jetzt weiter mit einem
letzten check das ab für mich freuen da
ging es um schuhe also schaut vorbei und
der trainerin schönen tag noch